hello leshaun hello carousel Oh Sammy
carousel had another premonition Oh what
was it this time she says an ostrich is
going to escape from the zoo today
no she heard that on the news last night
so that's the thing that actually
happened in real life already
okay well better late than never alright
I'll go make daddy some chamomile let's
go oh come on go around use the forth
good there you go lashauwn so I just got
this letter from an insurance company it
looks like we are officially on the same
insurance what yes I can't believe this
yeah we're finally not gonna be treated
like second-class to my god now I want
to see I want to see I want to see I
don't know don't show me just tell me
what are we covered better we cover it
how it's good insurance it would we get
dental oh my god make me an appointment
right now lashauwn a ruby filling and a
fang yes a single solitary Fang for
tricky fruits and bottle caps you
understand that that's kind of an
elective procedure to elect the fang the
president of my mouth and then I'm going
to get my voice loud and slow yes so I
can talk to birds alright so well I
don't know if we're gonna find a dentist
who can do that also it's not covered in
this assurance because just the basic
dental and vision that is my name I'm
gonna have one contact that looks like a
cat eye and another contact it looks
like a cat's face that's missing an eye
you don't wear contact I'm just have a
third eye that looks like a letter i and
it's gonna be in my eye I'm gonna be
like I see you sure you don't wear
contacts means to wear contacts when I
have my eyebrows redid cuz they say that
kind of procedure will scrumpet the
corneas you're not getting your eyebrows
redid redone undone done and I have them
switched on my face so when I get mad I
look delighted as you understand that
insurance is only for real medical
problems and even then we have a
deductible I'm going to deduct the fat
from my ass and put them in my phango
someone a wave I look like Mickey Mouse
okay all right listen to what I'm
telling you right now what insurance
it's not for you to have the bottom half
of your body caught off and you so into
a horse so you can experience what it's
like to be a centaur
Sammy that's a good idea it's not a good
idea because you died almost to me won't
be working semi it would be so worth it
please tell me I can I know that you
want to do that but you can't don't do
it it's not covered by the insurance
oh why you gotta be the 80s to my disco
right now why do you have to I thought
you don't I'm just trying to be the
reality to your emotions I'm gonna get
another stomach one for cherries in one
foot corn that's right Sammy I'm gonna
go to couples therapy alone and just
play both parts yeah I'm gonna go to the
gynecologist just ask questions til I
get it
oh and I got another question a few
questions about how many different parts
of your body you can make the link I
want to come on your lids done and let
my foot pockets foot pockets are this
invention I've been thinking of when you
can just put your keys up by your ankles
then I'm gonna have a coaster put on my
shoulder so when I go to a bar I can say
you want to drink on me and then I'm
just gonna be like a monster and if a
Halloween I'm gonna dress up like a
normal human being
you